le papa vers californicum est une fleur
ce après on s en doute fort et pourquoi
pas ce que ça prend la chaleur d'un
incendie de forêt pour faire éclater les
corses qui entoure la graine et
permettent à la fleur de jouer son rôle
elle est là d'un sol pendant 45 un ton
juste pour ce moment là où on veut avoir
besoin d'une nouvelle végétation qu'on
va avoir besoin qu'elles se manifestent
pour commencer une nouvelle forêt on a
longtemps comparé les êtres humains à
des objets cassés brisé quand ils
vivaient des drames les êtres humains
sont organiques est comme un territoire
incendiés c'est dans des contextes de
souffrance extrême qui arrive à trouver
des forces insoupçonnées des capacités
qui étaient là en ne savait même pas qui
était là alors on pourrait penser si on
veut créer la résilience qui suffit
d'attendre
c'est dans notre nature mais le danger
cependant qu'on atteint de passer de 0 à
moins 10 alors comment on peut faire
pour éviter ça mais une des premières
choses c'est vous donner la permission
de faire ce qui vous fait du bief
pourriez dire bon me semble que ça
semble c'est une évidence si ce qu'on
fait
malheureusement les drames les 13 10 10
épreuves à elle avec un espèce de livre
de règlements de croyance populaire les
gens ont souvent pêchent souvent de
faire ce qui leur ferait du bien parce
que pense qu'il faut que tout ce qu'ils
fassent à temps plein c'est souffrir
faire leur deuil
s'occuper de cette souffrance alors se
donner la permission c'est pas un mot
que je choisis par hasard
et pour l'illustrer j'ai une histoire
une dame qui m'appelle j'étais dans un
centre de crise qui me dit madame est ce
que vous pourriez parler mon conjoint
parce qu'il parle pas pu me semble ça
lui ferait du bien de parler bien sûr
mais monsieur voulait pas venir au
téléphone alors juste mais vous êtes là
tel qu'on peut prendre un peu de temps
avec vous qu'est ce qui s'est passé
alors leur fils de 21 ans était porté
disparu depuis quelques jours il y avait
fait tout ce qu'il devait faire il y
avait appelé la police cid avait cherché
mais depuis quelques années il avait vu
glisser tranquillement dans la
criminalité la drogue puis pensez bien
plus jamais retrouvé alors madame était
un petit peu plus calme ce qui fait que
je lui demandais mais vous dites que
votre conjoint par le pot mais qu'est ce
qui fait à la place de parler a dit mais
justement il ya commencé à rénover la
salle de bain
trouvez vous que c'est un bon moment
pour commencer à rénover la salle de
bain peut-être que c'est le meilleur
moment mais dites moi ç'a eu quoi comme
est fait pour lui
mais maintenant que vous dites ça a pris
une journée il ya passé une journée à
frapper dans un mur bien il ya dormi a
dépassé l'âge le de faire de l'ombre aux
constructions comme ça c'était la
première fois la première nuit qui
dormait depuis que notre fils et
disparus maintenant c'est vrai que y
arrêter d'être comme un lion en 15e sol
et rénovation ou est ce un bon là dedans
est quelque chose sur lequel il peut
contrôler qui peut contrôler jeu par
rapport à notre fils vin ne peut pas
faire grand chose
alors bien sûr je psychologue j'aime ça
que les gens parlent je trouve que ça
peut être utile mais j'ai appris avec
l'expérience que parfois parler c'est
pas suffisant
on a besoin de faire quelque chose de
faire ce qui nous fait du bien de donner
ses permissions là cet homme là ne
manquez pas de lucidité savent
exactement ce que c'était pas un si
c'est pas de la fuite n'était pas du
déni c'était de la survie
mais l'enseignement lorsqu'on a besoin
c'est de réussir à survivre
l'autre chose qui peut se produire quand
on vit un drame une épreuve ce qu'on se
pose des questions qui nous amène pas
nécessairement des bons endroits par
exemple une question qui revient souvent
c'est pourquoi pourquoi moi qu'est ce
que j'ai fait qu'est ce que j'ai fait
pour mériter ça
le malheur ne savent pas avec justice
sur les gens donc il arrive à certaines
personnes pont adolphe si on essaie de
trouver les causes vite comprendre
pourquoi c'est arrivé pourquoi ça nous
est arrivé à nous plutôt que quelqu'un
dont on trouve pas de réponse
ça nous arrive de trouver plus de
culpabilité alors pour moi il ya des
questions qui me paraissent beaucoup
plus utile c'est des questions qui ont
été répertoriés par insulin brigue ce
type de chez eux d'autres personnes qui
ont travaillé avec eux et permis ces
questions l'un bien commun est ce que
vous avez déjà réussi à vous en sortir
comment est ce que vous avez déjà
traversé d'autres moments difficiles
comme vous vous êtes déjà relevé comment
vous êtes passés de 0,1
peut-être de moins 1000 1 qui vous a
aidé qu'est ce qui vous a aidé parce que
peut-être que c'est le moment de
recycler ses moyens c'est pas quand on
vit un drame que en à l'énergie
d'apprendre des nouvelles stratégies
largement ces questions-là
systématiquement à mes clients que j'ai
droit tu sors de réponse entre autres
une réponse qui m'avait un peu surprise
une cliente qui me dit où un espace qu
elle parce que j'avais triche et puis là
je veux pas tricher cette fois ci le jeu
veut faire face à la souffrance je veux
faire les choses comme il faut sur ce
que je viens vous voir vous aviez
tricher qu'est ce que vous aviez fait au
juste
mais j'étais parti un an vivre dans mon
pays d'origine que je peux pas faire ça
j'ai des comptes à payer
peut-être que vous dites bien sûr c'est
pas possible pour tout le monde de
partir mais il suffit pas de partir pour
guérir
pour moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est qui ce
qu'elle avait fait pendant cette année
parce qu'elle était revenu qui me disait
qu'elle était mieux
alors qu'est ce qu'elle avait fait j'ai
insisté m par exemple j'habitais dans un
petit appartement mais y avait des
grandes fenêtres je l'appelais mon bocal
mais c'est un peu à l'image de cette
année là j'ai laissé un tri de la
lumière dans ma vie
j'ai laissé rentrer de la chaleur tue
quelqu'un d'un peu privé puis cette
année-là mais j'ai développé des
nouvelles amitiés j'ai laissé entrer des
gens j'ai suivi un cours de danse
j'avais toujours voulu faire ça puis
j'avais jamais osé alors bien sûr ce
n'est pas de la triche au contraire on
ne regardait comme on peut faire la même
chose à montréal et non seulement ça je
lui ai demandé je suis me semble qu'on
pourrait donner cette information en
plus de gens si tout le monde quand ils
vivent des drames s'assurait de regarder
ou est-ce qu encore de la lumière dans
leur vie ou est ce qu est la chaleur
c'est qu'ils les gens qui sont bons pour
eux peut-être osé faire quelque chose
qui avait eu cure et jamais fait ça
pourrait aider d'autres personnes
son histoire m'a inspiré mais une autre
m'a inspiré et ça va avec le thème de
rêver à un futur qui vaut la peine
peut-être penser que ça peut être
difficile de rêver pourquoi et dans le
futur mais c'est que souvent le sens
qu'on essaie de donner dans le passé
qu'on n'arrive pas à trouver on peut
arriver à donner un sens à ce qui nous
est arrivé mais dans le futur
c'est là qu'on peut trouver des réponses
qu'on veut choisir de donner un sens ça
prend d'imagination pour rêver mais ça
prend aussi de l'imagination pour
espérer pour croire qu'il ya un moment
qu'il y aurait autant de valeur sinon
plus qu'ils seraient plus grand que la
peine qu'on est en train de vivre un
moment pour arriver à faire passer de
0,1
parfois on a besoin de rêver à 1,10
rêver à un saint à quelque chose qui est
plus grand que la peine plus grand que
soi même
l'histoire de 20 viktor frankl donc
illustre cette idée là c'est un
psychiatre qui vivaient dans les camps
de concentration lors de la deuxième
guerre mondiale et y essayer de donner
un sens à ce qu'ils vivaient puis se
demandait mais ce qui fait que certaines
personnes arrivent à se battre pour
vivre alors qu'il y en a d'autres en
même temps dans les mêmes conditions
qui se laisse mourir alors essayé de
trouver les réponses d'un petit des
castes caractéristique personnelle
l'enfance de ces gens là le fait que la
famille était présente ou pas il n'y
avait pas trouvés et bien sûr était pas
un observateur indépendant de ces
événements-là lui même était affaibli
était atteint d'une pneumonie et s'y
retrouver un jour en direction d'un
chemin de fer étaient attachés à des
compagnons de fortune
il ya eu une quinzaine de tout et se
retrouver par terre puis s'est dit ça y
est je sais c'est aujourd'hui que ça se
termine yann et en asie qui ont mis une
arme à feu sur sa tante qui lui a donné
un coup de pied et crié des injures
hyacinthe une rage en lui
payeux flash et s'est vu à vienne en
train de donner des conférences sur les
horreurs de la guerre et sur le fait que
ce ne devrait plus jamais sur produits
et sans savoir pourquoi sans savoir
comment il a réussi à trouver la force
de se relever de mettre un pas devant
l'autre et il commence ce jour là mais à
partir de ce jour là ils se demandaient
mais est ce que ça pourrait être un peu
que tout le monde voulait faire des
conférences mais est ce que ça pourrait
être ce que tout le monde qui réussit à
se battre pour survivre un vais
effectivement des gens qui sans dormait
en rêvant la statue de la liberté
d'autres qui pensait rejoindre leur
famille d'autant que penser un combat
qui allait mener toutes ces personnes là
aussi porter attention aux indices que
peut-être que la guerre était en train
de terminer avant tendu des hélicoptères
ça veut dire que les alliés arriver donc
ce rêve là cette imagination là qu'ils
les aider à espérer de façon plus
humbles cette expérience leur me
rappeler des choses que j'ai vécues
entre l'âge de 4 ans et 9 1 il ya cinq
membres de ma famille qui habitait dans
la même maison que moi et qui sont
décédés alors j'ai passé vraiment
beaucoup de bons moments dans mon
enfance à me réfugier dans le futur en
fait j'ai développé la conviction que le
meilleur était à venir
vous savez comme tout dans ses films
commencent avec un drame qui se termine
avec du hakuna matata
alors moi je voulais rester pour la fin
du film je me faisais ça va être bon
j'étais curieuse j'avais hâte et non
seulement ça je me disais mais si je
suis resté en vie peut-être qu'à une
bonne raison peut-être que j'ai même un
rôle à jouer dans ce film là une
contribution que je pourrai apporter
quand j'ai commencé étudié en
psychologie
ce que j'ai appris c'est que les gens
qui avaient vécu des drames étaient plus
susceptibles de développer des problèmes
des problèmes de santé mentale des
problèmes de consommation des troupes
d'attachement il c'est vrai que ces
dangers lumpp il faut s'en occuper
aider les gens qui vivent cette détresse
là mais j'ai quand même à mes
professeurs à mes amis moi j'ai comme
j'ai l'impression d'avoir gagné quelque
chose à cause de ces événements là
c'était un moteur pour moi ça m'a fait
développer des croyances des convictions
qui m'ont aidé toute ma vie les gens me
regardaient le façon sérieuse et
sceptiques qu'ils aiment suppose que dit
la littérature
en fait c'est que ces recherches là ces
livres là n'avaient pas encore été
publiés
c'est seulement depuis quelques années
que ce qu'on apprend c'est clarisse
vient c'est pas un phénomène
exceptionnel juste pour des gens unique
ce quelque chose qui arrive à la
majorité des gens et non seulement ce
les gens qui vivraient des drains
pourraient seraient susceptibles de
développer une croissance post
traumatique
qu'est ce que c'est la croissance post
traumatique ce que parce que les gens
ont vécu des tragédies
il décide de prendre des décisions qui
auraient jamais osé prendre
il décide de faire du ménage dans leur
vie oui vous de la priorité peut-être de
leur relation il y apprécie la vie
une façon différente certains
développent un sens d'une mission
d'autres une spiritualité qui est plus
présent dans leur vie et qui fait une
différence
j'ai passé beaucoup de temps
mes premières années à travailler à dire
aux gens qui vivaient détriment des
deuils le faire attention à eux de
sauver irisé 10 de détérioration en tête
qu'ils pouvaient faire des cauchemars et
fallait qu'elle est plus triste qu'elle
ait irritable
je ne leur disait pas de remarquer les
indices de croissance post traumatique
mais si on porte notre toute notre
attention à ce qui peut aller mal on
peut passer à côté de certaines choses
qui sont en train de changer pour le
mieux
alors maintenant j'invite les gens à
porter attention à ça et là aussi j'ai
dû faire un exemple celui le plus
intéressant pour illustrer ce phénoménal
c'est un rien que je me souviens encore
de son visage candide un peu perplexe
qui me dit mais là tu me disais qu'il y
avait des choses qui allaient changer
mais je sais pas là mais il ya deux
personnes au travail qui ont demandé de
faire partie de mon équipe
choqué ce sas elle ferait un changement
c'est un patron qui me dit écoute
brigitte 10 parce que tout je ne
connaissais pas avant les événements le
tourisme a connu après que j'ai mordu la
poussière là avant le dans mon équipe
les transferts l'un s'était toujours
vers l'extérieur de mon équipe
les cinq hommes un sens unique ne
peuvent cependant surpris je n'ai que
les gens veulent sortir de mon équipe
est-ce que ça se peut que ces événements
là on fait en sorte que j'étais en train
de devenir un meilleur bosse mais je
pense que je plus humain ça ce moment là
je vide immense que je pense qu'il ya
des gens au travail qui ont commencé à
leur marquer avant vous alors si vous
vivez un grain
si vous traversez un moment 10 et ne
laissez personne vous dire que vous êtes
cassé ou brisés rappelez vous que la
résilience c'est dans votre nature et
pendant les moments les plus difficiles
porter attention à ce qui est en train
de changer pour le mieux
les premiers indices que le pire est
derrière vous ça pourrait vous aider à
garder espoir
et vous si vous pourriez être surpris
vous pourriez être étonné de ce que
votre résilience peut créer
[Applaudissements]